Newton's law of gravity states that the
further apart two objects are the weaker
their gravitational attraction becomes
dropping off with distance as 1 over r
squared that factor is related to the
surface area of a sphere that the
gravitational flux will be spread over
but what if we lived in a different
dimension in a 2d World gravity would
fall off as 1 over R the gravitational
flux would be spread over the
circumference of a circle in a
hypothetical four-dimensional World
gravity would fall off with distance as
1 over R cubed but gravity has already
been measured to fall off with 1 over r
squared so it looks like we've proven
that at least gravity only exists in
three dimensions or have we we haven't
been able to measure gravity on
distances less than a millimeter leaving
the door open for the possibility of a
hidden fourth dimension where it behaves
differently